[Musica]
sì
bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fatti j
e noi ci siamo sul primo dei due
speciali per il 500 mila iscritti tutti
ragazzi volevo innanzitutto introdurre
lo vi ringrazio tantissimo per questo
traguardo assurdo 500.000 iscritti sono
mezzo milione e pazzesco rega è pazzesco
ma non ci soffermiamo sui ringraziamenti
quello che vediamo dopo volevo dirvi si
chiude ho deciso dato che 500.000
iscritti sono un traguardo
diciamo un po diverso dagli altri perché
e mezzo milione e un traguardo il
traguardo particolare anche se gli altri
sono comunque speciali ma questo è
ancora c'è nel senso 500mila sono
500mila cazzo e siccome l'evento è
qualcosa di epocale ho voluto fare non
uno speciale ma ben due speciali o
lunedì o comunque in settimana faccio
uscire anche il secondo con che i
ragazzi questo è il primo dei due
speciali e mi scuso se non può accorto
perché comunque non è che potessi
registrare chissà cosa ma ho voluto fare
un qualcosa di completamente diverso che
non ho mai mai mai fatto e sto parlando
ragazzi del primo raduno che ho fatto ad
ascoli che ho fatto tipo 2 settimane
no la settimana scorsa mi chiami
ricordavo già più ragazzi è stato un
qualcosa di pazzesco cece gera non lo so
gente che si lanciava dalle finestre per
c'era una cosa allucinate ragazzino
ragazzi è stata una cosa inaspettata c'è
io non mi aspettavo veramente così tanta
gente c'è una cosa pazzesca e siccome ho
fatto ho visto dvd di quanto è successo
volevo mostrarvelo come primo speciale
fanno fare sempre le stesse cose volevo
farne due
ho voluto mettermi questo video bonus
nel quale vi faccio vedere come ho
vissuto quella giornata e ragazzi
preparatevi perché ha dell'incredibile
se voi non se non serve per caso non
eravate lì comunque sappiate che ne farò
altri raduni quindi non preoccupatevi e
niente vi lascio al video haga spero che
vi piace ho messo anche la musichetta di
sottofondo per renderlo un po più
caruccio anche che di ragazzi spero che
vi piace vi auguro buona visione
tocca adesso a tutti
a sviluppare a questo momento per fare
il 7
tra poco quando siamo quindi sei libero
sono visti
sì mi si sta sentendo un po della rai
[Musica]
no no no no ma non si nota che visto
leggermente cagando addosso
porca [ __ ] stata una cosa pazzesca
cioè io non veramente non ho parole
io ripeto lega è una cosa giorno mi
aspettassi e è pazzesco e io sono alla
fine sono come voi ci sono come voi non
è che sono alcune sono un ragazzo di 18
anni che si diverte a fare video è
veramente essere arrivati a questo è
qualcosa di allucinante io non ho
veramente adesso vi parlo come persona
seria per una volta è veramente
incredibile
tutto questo io vi ringrazio vi
ringrazio veramente di cuore per tutto
quello che è successo per quello che
succederà ancora perché non abbiamo
neanche iniziato ragazzi cioè non avete
idea di che cosa andremo a fare io lo so
purtroppo conca ragazzi io tutto questo
lo vedono un ottica diversa alla fine
non è che è lì ad ascoli c'erano tremila
persone per me secondo me era il
contrario sceglierò io andato per tutti
quanti voi per me i contrari ragazzi io
sono alla fine ragazzi tutto questo non
ci sarebbe se non ci foste voi quindi
siete voi da ammirare nonni o crediti
ragazzi io vi ringrazio di cuore per il
500 mila iscritti e niente ci vediamo al
prossimo video che sarà il secondo
speciale e spero di farlo uscire a breve
niente ragazzi per concludere io vi
lascio al montaggio finale e noi ci
rivediamo il prossimo vito bella ragazzi